字幕: Takahiro Shimpo
校正: Takafusa Kitazume
ここに一つの桶があります
桶は側板と呼ばれるものと底板
そして箍(たが) この三つの要素によって
成り立っています
箍が側板を締め付け
底が内側から張り出す
そして中に水が入ることにより
木が膨張して しっかりと密着し
水を漏らさなくします
では 今から
この箍を外してみましょう
観客: おお～
(拍手)
これが慣用句で言われる
「箍が外れる」ということです
この箍の締め付けと
この底の張り出しの
力のバランスが非常に重要で
それは職人たちの
経験や勘というものが
非常に重要です
それらは職人たちが
代々 手から手へと
引き継いできた
語り継いできたものなのです
私は桶職人の
一家に生まれました
祖父の丁稚奉公から90年
私が三代目になります
手習いの頃 父は私の指導に
細かな説明は一切しませんでした
「仕事は盗め体で覚えろ」でした
「こうやっ」と言って
鉋(かんな)で削って見せ
「やってみろ」
やってみて
「違う 貸せ こうや！」
の繰り返し
わけも分からず手を動かす
手が止まると
「考えるな 手を動かせ」
と叱られる
「仕事は手を動かして なんぼや」
「体で覚えるもんや」
「なんで？」と聞くと
「理屈は要らん」
(笑)
祖父は10歳の頃から丁稚奉公で
父は高校に通いながら
仕事をしていました
若ければ若いほど
仕事を覚えるのが速いし
長い期間 仕事ができる
という理由からです
ほんの60年くらい前までは
どこの家庭にでも
たくさんの桶が使われていました
ここの京都でも
およそ200軒近くの
桶屋があったと言われています
しかし 今は
３軒か４軒しか残っていません
それはプラスチックなどの
工業製品の普及により
桶の需要が激減したからです
そのことによって
桶屋の数も急速に減っていきました
祖父や父が手習いの頃は
一か月に数百個も
桶を作ったと言います
一つの部屋が桶でいっぱいに
なることもあったと言いました
しかし 今は一月に約 ―
約というか
もう数十個しか作ることはありません
父や祖父の時に比べると
需要は十分の一に激減しています
父や祖父が手で覚えていた頃の
手でこなして
体で覚えていったことを
僕がこなそうと思えば
彼らの一年分で
10年かかってしまいます
彼らの10年で
100年かかってしまいます
これは到底
追いつける量ではありません
では どうすればいいのでしょうか？
私は考えました
必死になって考えました
それで出した答えが
頭を使いながら
手を動かす ということです
そういう方法を使って
作り上げたのが
このシャンパンクーラーです
2008年に今までにないような
シャープな桶が作れないか
という話をいただき
挑戦して ようやく
２年ほどの歳月をかけて
ようやく完成しました
これは桶を作るときに見る
寸法表というものがあります
口径 高さ 勾配
箍位置 底位置などの
10個ほどの数字が書かれています
基本的にはこの数字さえあれば
桶を作ることができます
また 桶はレンガ造りの
橋などに使われる
アーチ構造というもので
形をなしています
一枚一枚の木片の角度は
正確に円の中心に
向かわなくてはなりません
先ほどのシャンパンクーラーを
作るには
非常に高い精度が必要になりました
丸いものから
楕円形になることによって
角度が非常に
難しいものになってしまったんです
それは 中心点が
一つではないからです
普段の丸い形であれば
職人の経験や勘というもので
形を作ることができます
しかし シャンパンクーラーは
この勘や経験というものでは
形にならないんではないか？
という風に感じるようになりました
実際に形になったものに
水を入れたときに
底板がみるみる盛り上がって
割れてしまったこともありました
力のバランスが崩れていたんです
私は桶の構造を見直し
アーチ構造に正確に沿うように
パソコンで図面を書き直しました
そのことを経てようやく
シャンパンクーラーは
完成したのです
父にこの図面を見せても
なかなか その構造は
理解してくれませんでした
しかし 私にこれができたのは
父や祖父が体で覚えた分量に
なんとか追いつこうとして
父や祖父に「理屈をこねるな」
と怒られながらも
桶の構造と道具の特性を
理解 研究しながら
体を動かしてきた
20年というものがあったからです
これができるようになると
今までになかったような
桶が作られるようになりました
丸い桶ではなく
三角や四角
五角形の桶なども
できるようになりました
そのことによって
桶を作る という
技術の可能性が広がり
デザインやアートの世界と関わり
日本から海外へと
世界が大きく広がっていったのです
私がやってきたことは
父や祖父 あるいはもっと前
何百年も続いてきた職人たちが
手によって語り継いできたことを
否定するものではありません
手から手へ語ってきたことを
言葉に翻訳し
桶の中に含まれていたものに
読み解いたにしか過ぎないんです
ここに一枚のスライドがあります
桶は修理修繕しながら
長い間使うことができます
残念ながら
この写真ではないんですが
200年くらい前の桶を
修理したことがありました
真っ黒になった側板の中に
昔の修理の跡を発見したんです
そして その桶の傷んだ箇所を
また新しいパーツと取り換え
組み立て直しました
桶は人との共存の中で
長く生き続けます
修理をしていると
その桶がどのように
使われてきたのか
昔の職人がどうやって作ったのか
ということを知ることができます
作り手から作り手へ
使い手から使い手へ
手から手へという形で
語り継がれてきたもの
それは人が言語を
持つ前から持っていた
最も原始的なコミュニケーションツール
なんではないでしょうか？
言葉は便利です
この世界は言葉によって
ほとんどのことを
言い表すことができます
でも全てではありません
言葉では言い表せないことがある
だから私はものを作ります
しかし 今 職人の減少と共に
大切なものが失われつつあります
職人の手によって語られてきた
技術や哲学や
精神といったものです
それを 手で
あるいは言葉に置き換え
次の世代へ受け継いでいくことが
必要だと考えます
以上です
(拍手)
ありがとうございます